y ya está en marcha el Abierto de
Australia el primer grand slam del año
se abre en melbour con un nuevo desafío
de la nueva generación al favoritismo de
Novak Djokovic y Rafael Nadal en la rama
femenina Tendremos una nueva campeona
después del retiro del australiana
Ashley Bari ganadora en 2022 Y qué
podemos esperar de los representantes
latinoamericanos para analizar esta
edición hablamos previamente con el
periodista Aries Rider quien no se
atendió desde la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Cuáles son las figuras a tener en cuenta
en el cuadro masculino
nunca se puede decir de Nadal que no es
candidato a nada porque sería faltarle
respeto a su trayectoria Pero la
realidad es que está con la peor de
racha de derrotas consecutivas de toda
su carrera ganó apenas uno de sus
últimos seis partidos lo cual Data de
que no está en un buen presente pero
como bien decías es el último campeón y
nunca se lo puede dar nunca se puede no
tener en cuenta Nadal hay un firme
candidato como lo es creo yo En todos
los torneos en donde juega que se
viene de ganar un torneo la semana
pasada salvando un en la final y es por
lo menos para mí el máximo candidato sin
lugar a dudas Por supuesto que que están
en quirios que siempre en los grandes
lamps se prende y da su mejor versión
está jugando en Australia en su casa con
su gente estamos el área SIM está holga
el Run hay varios de los chicos que
que sobre todo en la segunda mitad del
año pasado empezaron a levantar su nivel
y pueden
lo más grandes pero sin lugar a dudas
dio coaches el máximo candidato a Nadal
no se lo puede dar por descontado y
también que me estaba olvidando está
danime que es uno de los pocos que puede
darse el lujo decir que nombra en slam
que tampoco está en su mejor presente
pero siempre es uno de esos rivales
difíciles que no querés que te toque en
el cuadro
pasamos el cuadro femenino en el que
Prácticamente todo se resume a todas
contratic la polaca es la indiscutible
número uno del mundo ganadora de dos
grandes lams el año pasado la tenista de
21 años llegué en forma para buscar uno
de los dos grandes que no ha ganado Este
es el análisis de nuestro invitado
por lejos y sin lugar a dudas es la te
diría la única candidata porque en este
momento en las mujeres sobre todo ya sin
la presencia de Serena Williams sin
alguna de las jugadores que han que han
dejado su legado en la historia en los
últimos años es difícil encontrar una
candidata que no sea viatec está un
llave Ur que llegó a la final de wimble
en el año pasado que
tranquilamente puede puede dar pelea y
hasta puede ganar el título no hay dudas
pero Y fíjate que la favorita está
Jessica peula la estadounidense que
puede dar el batacazo por qué no
pero si no no hay duda de que es todas
con transviatek y va a ser la rival a
vencer de no ganar ella realmente puede
ser una incógnita porque podría ganar
podría ganarlo cualquiera no no hay
favoritas si no es ella no hay favoritas
algo es viática vamos a terminar esta
previa del Abierto de Australia hablando
de lo que podemos esperar de los
tenistas latinoamericanos entre los
hombres no se augura una Clara figura
tener en cuenta algo que sí ocurre entre
las mujeres
mencionaste a schwartzman no no está en
su mejor momento que es el tenista
sudamericano número uno
tampoco Francisco cerúndolo Sebastián
báez que son los tres argentinos y los
mejores rankeados no están pasando un
buen presente Cristian garín el chileno
tampoco está en su mejor momento pero
bueno es el tenis sudamericano sabemos
que tiene esa garra que que no van a no
van a dejar de pelear y pueden pueden
sacar a relucir su mejor versión eso no
quedan dudas No es un buen presente no
es un mejor no es un buen momento para
el tenis sudamericano pero pero
cualquier cosa puede pasar estar
colombiano Daniel gananal también que en
pistas rápidas puede ser de esos rivales
que no querés enfrentar Sin lugar a
dudas y estar con confianza puede dar un
buen papel y en las mujeres como decías
vos está Beatriz jadamaya la brasileña
que es una hasta te diría que puede
llegar a ser candidata puede llegar a
ser candidata porque es peligrosísima en
cualquier tipo de pista y sobre todo en
pistas rápidas y después hay que ver
están allá por Oscar que está volviendo
la tenista Argentina está Laura pivoz y
otra brasileña está Camila Osorio
Serrano también que que esperemos que
pueda dar un gran nivel porque no hay
dudas de que tiene el talento y lo único
que le falta es confianza para retomar
su mejor versión Así que veremos es un
torneo particular para los sudamericanos
porque Generalmente no tienen su mejor
nivel en Australia y esperemos que este
2023 se pueda pueda cambiar la historia